and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win you know who we are you know
we're here to rock guys we got an
exciting fun studio full of friends both
in episode friendship joining us from
the mouth knows it's a a wonderful movie
reviewing trivia podcast Empire Empire
my good friend Mark Ellis thank you good
to be here Sam Jason back rows we also
review car detailing where we can get
into in just a little I can't wait to
tell you the morning has been you're
like wait why'd you guys start to lay a
multitude of reasons but a lot of it has
to do with Sam's car also join us in
studio you've heard us talk about her on
the podcast a year and she has a
wonderful podcast called we three trolls
I know her as the Albanian okay Rosie or
fleshy am I here on Rosa's debut oh this
is exciting her cherry have talked
Buster how many times we have talked
about how literally the hottest girl in
the world yeah as a friend yeah
he is aw the reason I brought you all
three well you're always on the show
obviously my good friend Jason Tebow but
are you guys we all hang out the patio
all the time and I thought be good to
get us all together and I want to go to
talk movies now that we're coming up on
the Oscars as well and I wanted to get
into your podcast you tell us about we
three trolls
well we threw trolls I do it with Joseph
P Larkin and Webb Seville and yeah it's
literally Beauty and the Beast yeah it's
like rose and to unfuckable human beings
oh my god my mom saw the pictures they
grow to those man I know how long have
you known those man's view I'm like mom
don't worry about it what are those
man's she doesn't understand podcast I'm
like I'm on the radio
when can I hear it I'm like never do
something ever hear anything on there he
came all the way from Albania and now
his daughters do she's talking the worst
radio yeah what are you guys you see or
anything like that do not listen yeah
are so bad on I mean this is punch-drunk
so you're pretty safe yeah I mean you
guys are pretty bad they come up to you
know they actually were recording with
my friend Nick and he couldn't do it
anymore and they're like you're really
[ __ ] up you yeah you are rude like
okay yeah sure I told Dana I'm gonna go
through two hours of [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] stupid ass all which I hear
nightly at the Commons so you guys what
do you guys you troll people because
it's something based on fortune and for
those who don't know a fortunate it is
the it is the [ __ ] stain of the internet
it's like if the internet was underwear
it would be the [ __ ] stain of that am I
correct with that yeah you're right and
I'm I don't really know fortune cuz I'm
not on there very you're just there to
talk [ __ ] I talk about everybody and
everything fortune is just like a peer I
don't know if I'd say peer to peer but
it's basically where you just post
anonymously yeah crazy [ __ ] and it gets
it could be like really fun and funny or
it could be really dark and like you're
like other world is no way to assign
your name to it so it's not like reddit
for being anonymous or no you you could
put your name on it but most people
don't that's kind of it's like what the
it's the Wild West of the internet yeah
see the scary thing about that to me is
here a graffiti wait if I wanted to get
something out there I didn't want to
sign my name to it and I just wanted to
like vent you know I am worried that in
this day and age I'm gonna be tracked
down anyway like like even if I post
anonymously like somebody has the
ability out there to figure out where
this came from like you have to well
yeah I mean unless you're doing unless
you're so advanced that you can just
ping this [ __ ] like some people know how
to ping it off like 90 servers so it's
like almost employs I'm using the
Starbucks Wi-Fi yeah like you're gonna
be able to get there in a sec
yeah yeah you're not queuing Donna I do
such stupid [ __ ] with like I will be at
the airport on their Wi-Fi and like
looking at my bank statement like I
login this much stuff like I log into my
my credit card when I'm at a coffee
place just cuz I just I just trust the
internet I did it's there it's easy to
use and I'm sure other people are
looking at you're actually more apparent
than most people because I don't even
think of that
I don't everything all the time like I
don't give a [ __ ] I stroll people on it
like you bring up hey this is Suzy look
at her profile pic and you just go off
on her no but I would love to do that I
do that on my own when I'm drunk on
Facebook which is what Thursday through
Sunday at the Comedy Store every night
how do you survive you remind me of a
young Sam Tripoli 2002 no not on coke
just getting [ __ ] weird that's comedy
so nice by the way those are great years
yeah
my day starts off really good I started
off with like a green juice I'll try to
work out and then by the afternoon I'm
on tequila and then maybe some some
Peruvian cocaine I don't know at the end
of the night do they have I made coke at
the store anymore I feel like it's just
been terrible fat Eddie is just giving
everybody stepped on coke I don't even I
don't even mess with it it's so
disgusting
I'd rather pop an adderall if I must
that's I that I prefer that I respect
that yeah is that all good the drug
choice of school shooter it is good is
good Oh Johnny's given Oh real quick
let's get and then we'll get into some
funk I miss the boat and all the like
the fun drugs there's a coke guy ever
you don't seem like a code guy I mean I
drink anyone who drinks Budweiser or
Coors Light Yagami store I don't see him
as coke people they're like you know hey
dude I got my pissed beer but hey dude
let's do some yoga I was like accused of
being a cokehead early in my stand-up
career because I was like Shelby and I
was always sweaty wedding and I talked
fast on stage and like me and Brenner's
would get into arguments about Redskins
versus cowboys until five in the morning
a lot you don't think I'm very my view
you would say oh that guy's a coke cab
when you get closer you're like oh no
that's just a comic who got to started
talking to Brad
yeah then we realize they had to go home
when the trash man showed up that
morning the worst person to be around if
you're on cocaine would be brick because
he's all natural the only duck the only
dumber thing that I've done on cocaine
other than say hi how are you Brett what
I did cocaine on a red-eye flight once
Oh when you got on the flight got on the
flight would you wanna be gecko can a a
de flying submarine it's the worst
here's where it gets way worse they cut
off boobs cuz it's a red I do that every
everyone's asleep there's a 2:00 a.m.
curfew in the sky no but at some point
in time they're just they just will not
or did they cut you off you oh that's
happy I've been before
actually yeah I got well crazy foes
mid-flight they're like get the [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
the emergency exactly for like this is
our chair ready everyone's asleep so you
can't even like talk to anybody so you
can't smoke you can't drink and I want
to talk to it was a two-hour flight that
felt like a month a month dude imagine
imagine if you're like always going the
bathroom doing coke on a plane
everyone's like he's got bad bladder and
that dudes two employees
no [ __ ] the coke [ __ ] oh I had like I
like to consecrate yo that's cocaine
luckily I wasn't doing it all night
because it you know but I'd like to keep
bumps up and I did it and I was like oh
man now I'm [ __ ] that was really
stupid
well now this is gonna be just the worst
flight ever this Bell you're in the
hatch from lost okay like what are they
gonna come pick me up
just keep watching there's another
second another second another second so
let's get let's tell us about the shmell
I mean you've been on before everybody
loved you on the last one what's going
out to Schmidt you guys are putting on
this humongous like tournaments and it's
like yeah we actually think [ __ ] we
started this this movie trivia show
called the movie trivia Schmo down and
we just it was really just like a part
of our podcast so we tacked on at the
end and started picking up scene to the
point now where it's like it's it's only
we have multiple league
like a singles league in a team league
and a celebrity league you should give
that you should give us a movie to give
us some examples let's see how the three
of us do with some movie trivia I would
love to do that but I think you guys
could be 80 you guys could be like a
sports tit like because we always get
whatever team is competing we try to we
have like a wheel that you spin that you
could get a movie category from like you
know comedy or drama or romance or new
release you guys train would want to
have some run that will run the tables
on [ __ ] for Danny we don't have a porn
one yet we should have a porn Schmoe
down as easy would be like Houston and
Golden State we're like they're changing
the bracket so these two can finally
face each other in the championships
dude all I guess they've used this
master something that's all I'm saying
and if it's mastering [ __ ] trip or
trivia alone it I was gonna give you all
the credibility of just sports movies
right from yeah right from sports you
say that Tebow knife we were in it we'd
be like the UTEP of you the brackets
where we're like we we just we just
crushed a mid-major
but we're going in as a 16 seed against
Duke and we're gonna get [ __ ] house
yeah I see you guys just like one of
those wait like you won your first round
you know he'll be tough hanging over the
guys that are hung over but then you get
to the movie dorks and Sam and I are
[ __ ] yeah you're like we're like
Tennessee State you know you're gonna be
somebody in the first row you're gonna
upset like one of those teams it's eat
it too high like Iowa or Iowa State is
always like a two seat for some reason
you're gonna beat them and then you're
gonna run into Michigan State and then
you're gonna it the cream always rises
to the crows always gonna be a point
where Sam and I get outclassed that's
what you're saying
yeah but part of the show early but
eventually but you're our drug abuse
will show eventually catch up with us
we're like I don't remember anything
half the show is just is just like like
wrestling style trash talks so you're
having a pre-interview and you have a
post interview oh so the trivia is just
a small part of the performance and I'll
killing that you know who is the Michael
Jordan of movie trivia like the guy was
like that's the man right now it's a
Rachel Cushing is
ladies is one of the best in the league
she's going up against Sam Levine
who's an act he's been on he was in
freaks and geeks and inglorious basterds
and stuff like that huh and he has not
saluting girl maroon 5 right now that
would be Adam Levine and I think
probably had yeah I would love to have
it all of this man yeah that'd be great
I met that guy once outside of a bar or
a troubadour he was seeing the same band
I was seeing and John Bryant and so he's
stand out there and I'm smoking a
cigarette knows this [ __ ] guy saying
they're good I'll say good look he's
yeah I give you a good so I'm smoking
you know you could tell he had a buzz
going
I probably did too and I go probably
right now I go hey uh uh I got dude it
just must rain [ __ ] on you doesn't it
that's a Dom I got be honest with me bro
I just got to know how the good life is
it just rain he goes dude it's not
really like I mean you know it's not
like what you think it would be right
then two gorgeous girls come by and lose
their mind and I'll take a picture with
them and then they walk away and I go
you were just saying do I hear a great
story about him so he's at this party
right yeah and did you maybe you told me
the story I don't know but he goes to
the bathroom and Liam from Armwood no I
don't know that there's like - Liam's in
it I was betting against Denis one whose
whole family just crushed trivia guys I
look like he was it like Wonder Woman's
Island no I just get annoyed cuz they're
like oh you're from taken yeah nobody
knows I wear this jacket or too much of
an undercover cop jacket like this is
like I'm going after my daughter a
little bit yeah so he so Adam Levine
goes bathroom at in the bathroom is uh
Liam Gallagher Gallagher yeah and and
you don't Adam walks up he goes hey man
I just got to tell you that I'm a huge
fan of yours
and like I kind of my band has been
inspired by you oh god don't say that to
leave now
[ __ ] you your band saw her piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're awful [ __ ] don't
talk to me walks off right
what so so like an hour later Adam walks
through right and sees Liam again and
Liam's like are you [ __ ] still here
no way why are you here and goes it's my
party he was at his own [ __ ] party
laying into the dude didn't even know
where the [ __ ] he was that that's how
you know because Hindman like so aces
famously broke up because the brothers
brothers were fighting so why would he
offer you any more respect
they're just yeah some guys are just are
like that to be like that like there's
this great story about like the Rolling
Stones tried so hard in the 60s to be
the anti Beatles for a time because the
Beatles had this nice clean-cut more
handsome image and parents were freaking
out about the Beatles so imagine how
they thought about the stones there's a
story that you know the band Herman's
Hermits yeah you know woke up this
mornin feelin fine so nailed it Mick
Jagger walks in later stuff that special
Pelican said it's like if the Warner
Bros so Mick Jagger walks into a bar and
sees the lead singer from Herman's
Hermits and the guy I think his name was
Peter Tudor Peter Tourisme yeah man he
walks up and Mick Jagger just seat and
just punches it just punches him for no
reason other than he was in Hermits
Hermits but do you think that punch hurt
perfect yeah girls like Mick Jagger
could throw punch very tiny my bigger
man than make John oh yeah
if I feel like he would do it the wrong
way I feel like it'd probably hurt big
Jagger but based on the previous
conversation we just had when you are on
certain drugs you might have strengths
that are hidden to the public I actually
now that now that I see Herman's Hermits
I want to punch all five of them myself
especially the little one in the middle
I want to kick his face I know you look
at that
don't you say thank God for black people
like oh
[ __ ] if we did up like people we'd still
be doing this [ __ ] yeah not even
good-looking white people you know those
guys talk about Hendrix after a show a
while he was really interesting I look
like an orphanage like other orphanages
Christmas okay all these kids are quite
adoptable kids that's great Hey
all right back to the orphanage yeah do
you have any dates coming up anywhere
you're gonna be actually we got a big
one in the movie trivia sure our first
live event if you see one live event in
March see Sam's show at the Viper Room
okay if you see two live events in March
at the portal Theatre in North Hollywood
oh [ __ ] go big we're taping our first
live movie trivia Schmoe town we have a
great undercard which is the real
rejects versus the wild berries and then
the the marquee matchup the main event
is JT E versus John the outlaw roca like
everybody's got their own nicknames and
it's a fun show and obviously Chris and
I will be there Hosting I'll probably
come out and and do a little stand-up
top like the kids up you get me in a
theater that's like packed in front of
like 500 of my closest friends we're
gonna get to the trivia and all the
other stuff I'm probably gonna want to
say a few you oh man I love it probably
gonna want to do like I said let's um I
don't think you get enough credit for
what you've done in this town and how
hard you you and your boy you guys know
what happens when I slow down it's
mostly Christians baby and he's great
and you're touring a lot I know you work
we'll have our friends but you're also
do your own weekends and I don't think
people realize like like how hard it is
to do what you've done well it's like
and you guys kind of like did before
what I think everybody's doing now which
is like I'm just all in on the Internet
it's my pod my other podcast this
podcast and touring off of those things
like I'm doing that I've been doing that
for the last year and a half whereas you
guys have really gone all-in on that a
long time ago and it's like really
starting to beer the fruits but it's
interesting to me with like utorrent
where the podcast is one thing but like
I think it really shows that if you have
an audience it shows up you need to be
able to do something that's more than
just your podcast it like live because I
personally like I show up and I see
people do a podcast that's fun but if
you can actually have the comedic
background that really we all have and
you can bring that to a stage I think
that that ups the ante for a crowd like
they want to see people that not only
are good at their podcast they
appreciate their podcast but they want
to see somebody who can do a live show
well so hopefully we very well ask ya
come and see it showing something else
what are our Mo's groupies like by the
way are they it's a lot more diverse
than I thought it would be ours are
exactly 22 year old boys that's like
when I when we started you guys get the
cool cosplaying hot chicks who show up
like dressed like poison ivy here's
something great like snacks
at Comic Con last year there are
multiple people caused by both men and
women cosplaying as us yeah and like
characters from the [ __ ] from like from
like the Schmo down and like from our
show and that freaks you out I love it
it's like somebody because it's awesome
to see it then you're like wait somebody
had to spend like hours thinking about
how can I dress like Marc Riley or like
John Roca they're like me it's like
somebody had to sit down and like look
at a picture for a long time and put
that together
my cars being used in a bank robbery
right now I think I'm almost positive I
think it's a good thing this show goes
for about two hours because it'll be
back yeah from wherever it is it's like
remember well you'll know for sure in a
vacation it's just like Hong Ki lips the
side it's just on break signs it's like
all graffiti like no tires gone it's
just stripped frame of a car it's just a
frame of a car on brick how were you
gonna be Jason follow me on Twitter as
always you can find out what dates and
what clubs gonna be doing if you're in
Los Angeles
and listen to 92.7 the pot with the new
ones coming out in about two weeks we're
starting record tonight with Jon REEP
and Sarah Tiana Oh a bunch of funny
people are gonna be on that so please
subscribe that give us 9 thumbs down and
suck it alright I am going to be at the
dirty show in Ontario with the smash
brothers tomorrow night then I'm back in
Vegas for the naughty show Pet house
presents the naughty show live at the LA
comedy club in stratosphere we have
Jenna Kenna James she's gonna be pals
pet she's gonna be out we're giving away
top coat oi vibrators go to top coat top
coat toys comm check out the [ __ ] and
that Friday and Saturday night is tin
foil hat comedy night mean Eddie Bravo
we will be live there at 11:35 live
tickets are available at to get to are
available that the LA Comedy Club calm
that should pack out and then again as
Mark mentioned I am shooting my special
it's called
zero [ __ ] that's what we're going with
zero [ __ ] I like that last week we were
debating names you clocked it on 0 I'm
gonna go over the other contenders
Armageddon because I'm I just feel like
I'm just doing it because that's what
Hollywood wants I feel like that might
be a little too limiting to because like
because you do you do that Armenian
benefit every year yeah and but that one
is is geared towards I'm having a full
Armenian audience and so at like zero
[ __ ] it's like for everybody it's
actually the whole title is gonna be
nothing to lose zero [ __ ] to give but
it's gonna be called zero Fox I like
that the zero [ __ ] tour yeah yeah so
I'm gonna go out there and shoot at the
Viper Room rate the reason a lot of
people have emailed me I haven't gotten
back to you because I'm figuring out the
times I think it's gonna be seven thirty
nine thirty
Jason gülen's opening for me and I yes
ii i just seagull learn about leave are
you [ __ ] kidding me
this whole thing is [ __ ] free
if you know why I loved learned was the
brings his own beer and I'm like don't
sell that yeah it's always like some
off-brand yeah yeah you know and I'm
just like oh hey Rose I [ __ ] love you
dad I love you
yeah O'Brian's that place down in like
tennis and they use some Running Room I
think they say okay so back in the day
was like a hot room and but galloon but
always call me when he was doing it dude
do they have [ __ ] rent winter steam
light and I'm like nobody has that cool
I'll rip the label off I'm there in five
baby yeah you don't tell he's the truth
craft beer enthusiast because he does
not mind drinking why if I took degrees
because they always were a bit like
cider Joe's beers his wife just yeah she
Shops at his bar all day but he doesn't
mind Krakatau but like if my beer is any
warmer than thirty two point one degrees
I caused it you Rosa I will cause a
stink yeah dude how about a noise
matters of Dorothea
oh nice Dusseldorf ale so go to just go
to our email Sam Tripoli live at gmail
and I'll get you on the list it's
probably gonna be 739 three I'm just
working out the details
seats are limited toes get on it's
probably gonna be well at the most 150
but I'm thinking it's gonna be a hundred
people to show have you done stand-up at
the Viper Room yeah yeah I love it
because I know they do like a show there
occasionally but here's the first
special I've ever heard I have to the
only thing I have to work on is that the
the stage is so high the crowd below I
can't do my whole act looking down
because then it's just gonna be a weird
shot so I'm gonna have to be looking
towards the people who are standing in
the back that's gonna be the heart the
biggest thing but I'm hand picking each
[ __ ] coming into this thing each
[ __ ] but it is emails like make
a cut my this hot comic was like I love
bringing five of my friends I'm like it
not happening you can come in because
you like me button you're not bringing
you and your crystal you'd come
dumpsters into my [ __ ] show so they
go oh oh oh
babe I don't need any of that okay no
speed bumps we're just [ __ ] hitting
gas and we're going transporter on this
shoot it's used a little
it's tough man starring mmm get there
Liam Gallagher who is in the transporter
I know them I see him get there he
fights Albanians Oh James head no that
looks tough with it yeah we said the
mechanical and has a game of somebody on
your show Helen wants to be Jason
Statham very good very good
[Laughter]
yeah so do that so yeah I mean you you
guys are always on the patio and you
guys have been at the Comedy Store for a
very long time
remember when Rose learned at work in
there yeah I think we all do for the
rest of our life I think about that
moment every morning lady what did I get
made of regular yes the end of 2007 okay
did you you worked a door right
I worked yeah I worked everything I
worked a lot I worked the door I worked
phones for a long life my life was spent
on the phone for a period of time
because I was telemarketing in the
morning cuz you know when you're in that
weird stasis period when you can almost
quit your other job because you're doing
okay with comedy but you're not quite
over the hump yet like you need like one
more road date a month or whatever else
you got right so I was telling marketing
from 6:00 a.m. to 2:00 p.m. and then I
get off work and then I go to the store
and be there by the 4:00 p.m. I think
that's when the switch was to work the
phones up to the show and then pop in
the o.r the main room booth or the
parking lot to work there so it was like
it was a very exhausting period but by
the end of 2007 when I got made a
regular I stayed on just for the
late-night
o our Saturday shift because that way
like if a comic doesn't show up I'm like
legally allowed to pop onto the show and
do 15 minutes or whatever but yeah I
mean I said I have nothing but the great
memories rose when did you get start
working their way year 2011 2011 Jason
you've been there since what 1999-2000
right yeah so we've been around for a
while weird person I third comedian that
I met that little is like my peers was
number one
I met go learned of the second day I
lived but you hated each other you
and I made that happen you're welcome I
made you guys go learn how to rivalry
yeah I go I go
you guys are gonna love each other you
guys will love each other yeah the first
show I ever did here is I've been in LA
for like two days he was the host of it
at that place called la cabaret theater
if you remember that room it went
through a lot of different iterations
well actually did a show there it was
like they do comic burlesque dancer
comic burlesque dancer so it was like a
back and forth so the audience is like
what the hell is going on right now but
the room was gorgeous like did they just
get rid of the room I mean like
physically right now do you remember
where the where was I want to say was on
Melrose but I'm not no no it was it was
I'm Ventura Boulevard it was in like
almost two Sherman Oaks I was in Germany
but it was way in the back in the back
corner yeah it's like a strip mall and
it's ran by the biggest dick in the
world it was like it had two rooms they
like a main room and like oh never
Robert Blake killed his wife trivia what
they had a back room of atella zeta - oh
- now do you do you think that helped or
her business for Robert Blake no it's
questionable you probably got a couple
more oh I think initially it's a dip and
then it's a huge spike I think maybe
like people crazy enough they go they're
like dude the San Francisco Zoo somebody
was dumb enough to crawl into like the
lion's cage and the lion attacked it the
next day was the biggest gate ever at
the zoo people want to watch train
wrecks and car crashes so people like
where did she step before you shot her
well right there can I get that seat
today what happened to the line did the
well I thought everybody showed up just
to see a lion [ __ ] a human face yeah he
just poked the femur you ever see the
picture where these villagers went to
jungle they finally say to cut open they
saw their friend inside yeah like how
[ __ ] no no there's no way that's a
real kick you know it is really well I
will fall the biggest rabbit hole I can
fall down is watching snakes eat
things I can on you just the way that
they just the way they slowly like
unhinge their jaw and they just work on
it like they just evil I dated a girl
who do that like Black Hawk ad working
dicks remove her bottom jaw get my balls
and my dick in her mouth and your
designs how thirsty are you know black
[ __ ] ad is oh we call her 401k Katie no
yeah she's black [ __ ] cake okay alright
401 K T is funny
she always drinks for free on the at the
Comedy Store she put enough years in
there a hundred percent let's our last
night briefly
oh she was she at the store briefly yeah
she's banned by the way I will Tiger
band at the comedy stores two months
right can we agree on that pretty much
unless it is who's that kid that always
shows his little dick on stage and got
kicked out of there Oh Kenny Kenny Kenny
Kenny Lyons yeah yeah
Kenny lying shows little Asian dick
everywhere dude that thing looks like I
like I someone broke a thumb in half
he's like if I work with dr. ken it will
work for me by the way he doesn't [ __ ]
anything like I love Kenny but yeah I'm
not sure why but he has not been around
he's definitely not under that weight
got a dude it looks like he sleeps on a
skateboard and that's me saying it well
he's like who's the other guy they used
to hitchhike all the time like people
try to blow him Ricky Luna no Jared
balloon 11 Jared Levin yeah Jared Levin
would be like yeah all three of those
guys in the same place at the same time
at the Comedy Store
it's like June yeah it's like Edelman
and [ __ ] and I was always engine all
those guys are the same guy it's like
okay do you guys remember when he used
to do the marquee and misspelled
everybody's name in there they had mr.
dam before him with all the [ __ ] up
names the way he spelled it he had no ID
down and [ __ ] yeah why everybody they
just had to keep order this so bad
so you've been you've been at the
podcast for awhile you've seen it like
when it was like what the [ __ ] is going
on here and then you're like it's what
it is now I mean the store yeah like
whoa you've been on at the Comedy Store
for a long time you've been bartending
there you've seen the craziness yeah
like do you like it more now because you
probably make it more money or do you
like the more outlaw definitely liked it
more there's more okay so when I first
started there I would show up they're
like sorry you got cut and I was like I
just spent my last five dollars on gas
money they're like well you can have
chicken tenders well what the [ __ ] dude
like what yeah so like we would get cut
like three of the six shifts that I was
scheduled so they can't even eat the
fingers cuz you're about to do coke
right you're like no dude I'm good I'm
good on that to go back it's got way
better I mean I think with the return of
Joe Rogan a lot of credit for these
everything to their yeah
and you can tell it when he is not in
the lineup it is a different vibe
completely different and it's like III
forget it
BRR as well birth is another but Rogan
is legends there every week brokens
there gets there and you could you can
it's measurable
like literally measurable the reaction
from crowds when he's on the lineup
versus when he's not on the line and the
rooms fill up I mean BER will sell out
as well but he's he's the anchor always
the anchor well broken has been and
always will be the nicest guy in the
world and that he puts his name on the
[ __ ] marquee and he helps it dude
makes care everybody man he's he's
wonderful I really that guys love bread
his wealth to everybody I would be a
[ __ ] homeless bum if it wasn't for
that [ __ ] guy he's great and I've
said it on stage before but it's like
yeah he takes care of people that he
believes in and he thinks are good yes
he's not gonna give you the time of day
if you did that for yourself but he
helps his friends that are good people
and that are good at what they do do you
miss the outlaw Ness though but be great
like Eric locking all the doors no dark
spaces anymore this guys doing hunting
Tibo should do a whole segment called i
found a weird place to [ __ ] at the
comedy so are you just fine nice show
what's going on it's true I did that and
that's a pride I take Carlos Mencia was
on stage I [ __ ] behind that weird
curtain where the waitresses walk oh
where the where the lights are yeah
there was these two chicks we turn the
lights and then that's where I was sure
I was gonna see a ghost maybe not
necessarily to humans [ __ ] the like
right I thought I'd walk back there and
number three that's where the ghosts
would be because like you opened this
little tiny curtain and that's where you
turn the lights on and off in Sam just
telling Kristen used to give me hand
jobs back there every night we just meet
in the back just fun after a few times
or is it like it's like you're just
clocking in at this point at this point
clocking in but I still enjoy clocking
in yeah hang on I got a 12:15 I don't
want a job for myself yeah so there's
these two chicks in not tonight Jason
not tonight there's these two chicks use
hangout County so they were both from
Louisiana and I always say this that
white girls from Louisiana are number
three on my super freak big board it
goes Latinas and then it goes ah baby
chicks and anger then Latina and then
now white girls from Louisiana cuz and
then it turned out there basically
hookers
yeah well though yeah but they were they
were off the clock at the store
ironically enough hookers is number four
in his list at the store because if
you're talking about because like the
stories just like that that kind of like
that bug zapper for like all different
sorts of like like lightning rod for
insanity but are they there to blow off
steam after work so if you pick up a
person who is a lady of the evening at
The Comedy Store and you are you paying
for sex or did you earn this with your
charm or your personality like it says
is this in pursuit of a relationship for
them you're like I'm picking up overtime
here yeah I don't know the answer to
that is it you gotta ask them are you
clocking in for this there's just like a
[ __ ] offer but it's job coming it's
hard to bring that if you had a legit
good conversation yeah you want to go
back to my place they say sure like it's
hard to bring that up like so just to be
clear there's no transaction happening
right other
bodily fluids like that's the only thing
we're not that's Marcus raw dog
everybody raw dog it superstar I'll get
to first base with anybody I'm just like
I'm a fly i watch I feel like you tried
to find dark places crime so it's just
to hold hands I did Rick Ingram has a
running joke that all I do is I HiFi if
I high-five a girl the end of the night
that's like yeah I got laid that's my
version of getting laid is just like
yeah high five yeah it's good tiny I
figured a girl with another guy's dick
the other day oh really congratulations
boys
that's crappy way to wrestle open mic
errs late night all the time I don't
know Paul yeah do you think it's crazier
now than it was late I feel like maybe
I've aged out of it that's why I don't
see it at all everybody knows I don't do
coke anymore yeah but I I feel like I've
aged I mean like I feel like the girls
were crazier back then like there were
some chuckle [ __ ] and we've talked
about the yak for and I mean it and all
due respects like Mensch mint sounds
like a bad words like this guy's a real
match like why would he do to you you
know it's a nice word chuckle [ __ ]
that thing - there were these chuckle
[ __ ] and I feel like they're not
there anymore but maybe I'm wrong oh
they're there they're there they're like
why would I [ __ ] my dad yeah just spread
out yeah just there's more comedians
when we were there eight like people
like Dahmer arrow were like I don't
think there's any chuckle [ __ ]
anymore I respect that I respect and you
and I just sometimes I just analyze the
same check not a thing with each other
that night okay that's good
no I mean I hung out a lot of late late
nights and so but but if you're not
putting the hours in late night anymore
then you're not gonna see it you know I
mean I feel like I tell her later I see
it that's what I'm saying is it's still
there late night a lotta story in the
show the other day I was talking to this
girl there and she turns out she's 21
and and she was like how old are you and
I'm like oh just turned 45 she goes my
dad's 45 no I got a shot oh he just
broke me in half
what does that do to you if you did you
here
like I was you go home and for when she
was born
yeah no dude I don't at all I'm cool
with my age too
I mean I have a theory about this is
that like for whatever reason comics
just have a repressed sort of growth and
it's more mental and emotional than
anything else but like I'm I'm 37 years
old I still feel you look like [ __ ] like
I'm 25 right but I could and it doesn't
matter like I look like a certain age
but I feel like I literally feel like
I'm mid-20s and it's maybe because I'm
single or with it but I feel like same
way I do not feel I don't but I your
white night I thought I wouldn't notice
on my edge like oh my god I feel like
I'm like towards me right calculators
are crunching numbers no but when you
when you're talking about how you feel
you're tied in and you hear the number
you're like I'm gonna be close to dead
yeah yeah yeah and you are technically I
mean like I I'm making no - I should
because right now I kept yeah me yeah
I'm 25 years maybe less maybe and that's
okay I'm fine with up you're fine get
back into cocaine take me under on 25
how are you right now
I have 90 days left to live you're 45 so
if you still little you're 70 I have
more Leandra live no I'm taking the over
but you're not gonna like why I'm taking
the over no because I just have you
carved out as the guy that's gonna be
around the comedy store when you're 75
are you telling me I'm Johnny Sam I was
gonna give you Steve Kravitz but like
you're gonna be yeah and you're gonna be
telling the kids like ah you know who
the first special the Viper Room was no
naik my cuz he loved to talk you love
talking to people I do I mean I I'm not
saying I won't be visiting there I can
see being like I mean like I've been at
the Comedy Store longer than lived with
my parents you know what I'm saying like
from the moment I pop down my mom snatch
- the moment I left for Vegas I've been
at the store longer so it is in me by
Sam a contender for what you said and
because there's going to be another
argos Hamilton no no like as far as
another guy who comes in and just slight
like is the older the elder states and
it's not wreaking grow I think it'll be
Rick Ingram or it will be Brody Stevens
making room only won't do that if his
wife just shuts it down like you've done
it enough like what I could see that
happening I just is too clean like he's
his jokes are funny but his more
political he way funnier you forgive him
he's great you're dirty you're dirty
[ __ ] yeah warrior yeah no jokes
about licking [ __ ] last night I felt
so bad I walked up to all the female
comics and apologized to them I'm like
listen I didn't realize he imagine if
Argus did your jokes on stage that would
be [ __ ] hilarious but I won't be I I
think all the time now it's like maybe I
think everybody has to leave the comedy
store at some point and even if you come
back everybody leaves at some point you
just it's just the nature of that where
you can't be there forever I bet and
I've had a great run I think sometimes I
have to go away for a little while
try my kung-fu elsewhere and then come
back after a couple but it's just like
dude it's the nature of the beast it's
like you don't get to be in the dojo
forever well that's I mean but that's
more two comics who think that you need
to go to one club and that needs to be
your home because people hear us talking
about how the comedy stores our home I
think in their heads they think like oh
I can only I should only go to the
comedy store and that's it's like no you
should go to every club you should you
should go as much as you possibly can to
as many clubs as you can but the store
is gonna feel like you're home but
you're you should branch out like nobody
wants to actually stay at their home for
the rest of their lives they want to
come visit well I think that because the
stores Mecca right now it's always been
Mecca but now that's like getting the
love it is now it feels like it right
well you know what else is happening now
is what I noticed there's a lot of paid
regulars from years ago that are trying
to get a little bit of that Mecca you
know they're trying to get that energy
back
I'm like bro who the [ __ ] are you they
come in the back as I'm and then I'm
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] out
of here that you're why are you in the
kitchen though I'm so-and-so and my name
is on the wall I'm like prove it where
is it on the wall and then I gotta
apologize and [ __ ] like that but it's
like that's why you shouldn't disappear
because yeah show up like just keep
doing your thing don't but dude when you
got so many spots over a very
long time you can't expect that to
happen forever no the truth is that
there's other people who need to I don't
I don't need that stage to learn anymore
I am it is in my but if you cut me right
now it would be red and black you know
that's what will come out of the
connoisseur mostly because I'm dying
okay but it's in my great no matter
where I go I bring the Oro a tude to the
stage right yeah and it's it's selfish
for me to think that I um I should get a
ton of spots for 20 [ __ ] years there
and it's just like maybe that day will
come back and i 100% believe it will
where i will get more spots but it hurt
at first when you get your spots go from
four down the two to one and you're like
[ __ ] man but then you're like it's time
yeah it's time to let other kids get a
little peace yeah and that's why I
started to dojo down the street because
I do want to get up and do stage time I
do want to would not to [ __ ] get
better but work to new jokes but I
understand that that the young kids need
to get that [ __ ] ort that not that
only come from doing that [ __ ] is there
a if there's a professional sports
franchise you're gonna compare the
Comedy Store to is there any other team
besides the Oakland Raiders that you
think would be it would be a better
comparison because I always love the
late-night Roy Pistons that's a good one
the pista for sure where it's like yeah
grit grime no [ __ ] no gimmicks no
nothing I love watching there's a couple
people who kind of come in a little more
famous and they could cheat a couple
things here and there but there's no
faking the funk on that [ __ ] place
and it all comes down to there you know
what I think it is well first of all
that they're all ours vodoo I've seen it
break everybody yeah
you can't lie in there especially at
1:00 in the morning oh there's there's
like five people and they're all hammer
time yeah talking everything's been
talked about
everything's been talked about already
[ __ ] I'm not hurt yeah and that's the
comic that just got offstage yeah he was
still on stage that Victor goes I was
there for the [ __ ] comes out and
starts yelling at
I was there for the [ __ ] contest I've
always wanted to shoot Holtzman without
him no elephant gun and just shoot it
shoot it shoot it shoot it shoot it not
let him know edited together and be like
can we release this we do it do it
he's a self-sabotage or do it I was at a
special at the that he shot at that bar
yeah I told that we can well use that do
it probably a 2006-2007 some [ __ ]
because I like the reason why I would
want Sam to do something like that for
Holtzman is because you do get those
comics to come along that they are like
you said even if he's not like a
self-sabotage sure there's certain ones
that are like if if you could have shot
James painter back in the day and put
that together because nobody really buys
what we're talking about when we refer
to paint her beak I don't even think I
don't think I were around that but like
that's another guy that we should have
filmed yes Jim painter he's so good and
he's like just especially he makes me
cry laughing nice I've seen everything
everything but the late-night guys are
by far my favorite because they can't do
their comedy really they just got to
start yelling at people and he's the
best at it because he's being [ __ ]
honest this is about holtzman [ __ ] about
the guy in the wheelchair at the wedding
have you ever heard that man about how
the guy in the wheelchair ruins every
picture at the wedding because he just
keeps [ __ ] and they're like okay get
in there it's like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
know hey just like your roadie
everything the picture I just love how
he takes a crowd down like because he'll
talk normal and the crowd is just silent
but they're hanging on every word and he
just lets that he lets that build for so
long and and when we're watching the
back we know it's gonna pay off but they
don't yet so it just starts to get that
anticipation why the [ __ ] are you or get
the [ __ ] out here there's one lesbian
got up and like started yelling she's
like [ __ ] you you think anybody cares
what the [ __ ] you gotta say you stupid
Dyke [ __ ] he starts going in and I'm
just on the word crying laughing we're
cleaning up because we're dead on the
inside
it made me feel so good and you know
what you know what that won't probably
ditch probably went home and thought
about it yeah
hard for about a month yeah okay changed
her life dude
there's one time then she killed herself
said something on stage yeah - a woman
died go that is going to affect her for
the rest of her life
mm-hmm and dude he was doing stand-up
and it was one of those it was one of
those nights where Rogan wasn't there
and the crowd was just super politically
correct and super [ __ ] weird
and he was like he was like she's talk
she goes are you talking can you be
quiet blah blah blah she's like what's
your point he goes my point is you can't
be a four and have a shitty attitude the
whole room just stopped and her job goes
cool she needed to hear it sometimes
people need to get lit up yeah I've
gotten lit up many times I'm like whoa
that it's life changing
yes life changing you just have to be
embarrassed in public sometimes till you
become a better person that's my life
yeah so I know you don't know a lot of
sports but I want to get into Kirk
Cousins
yeah they are talking about him possibly
getting 50 million dollars guaranteed
first year by the Jets the Jets have
said that they want to give him the max
that they can guarantee a player that
the current you know collective
bargaining agreement will allow you to
do that so I don't think that Kirk
Cousins is worth that money but I'm a
red ski I'm a huge Redskins fan you've
got 60 in the last three years I also
think Kirk Cousins is one of the better
quarterbacks in the league and I think
the quarterback is it's such a premium
that you need to lock down somebody I
think the Jets have a team that's ready
to go to the next level everybody
thought they're gonna lose every game
last year and they they they won some
games they were competitive in a lot so
they need a lot of I think that Kirk
Cousins could be that biggest piece but
I am just I'm so disenfranchised with my
team I would never ditch the Redskins as
my favorite team which is I find a
detriment my personality because you're
a little less [ __ ] nice to be around
dude
way that they the way that that front
office has just never given Curt cousin
liking it liking a team that's shitty
your entire life is like being married
to a [ __ ] lying [ __ ] yes a car very
much money for me to leave this
situation I have too much merch hanging
in my closet to jump ship but seriously
is it better to have that [ __ ] is
killing me where you've had you've had a
shitty relationship from the start yeah
with like or is it better to have like
cuz I have all these memories from when
I was a kid of Super Bowls and great
times and Joe Gibbs and Doug Williams
and Mark rippin and the diesel and I
have that juxtapose with what the
current gone off there more like a
regular American marriage where it
started Matt everything was great you
had some kids everything went good yeah
now you're [ __ ] hated yeah dude you're
crazy here's the thing about your
ownership the New York Knicks and the
Phoenix Suns are a great example of how
when your ownership is so bad it bleeds
down to the rest and organization it's
like when we we've all had families or
friends whose dad or mom or batshit
crazy and they just ruin the entire
family that is when you have a bad the
Phoenix Suns owner has destroyed that
fan choice and sometimes it's really as
simple as just putting an arm around a
quarterback and saying like you're our
guy I believe in you there's a great
story I think it might have been an ESPN
the matter is something else where there
was RG threes rookie season right and I
love RG three I wouldn't trade that
season for anything because that was the
first time I felt real hope as a
Redskins fan in a long time
RG three gets hurt Kirk Cousins comes in
plays very well against the Cleveland
Browns on the road in Cleveland in an
important game and I was actually at
that G is like winning a big WNBA game
right it is to interrupt but I'm looking
at that bottle over there oh boy and you
guys don't mind if I take a shot do a
shot tequila and let me make a point
about that quarterback and we said on
this show I'll be right back RG three
looks like a catfish Johnny
and you come back a sugar bomb I could
give you that we need radio for yeah no
see rg3
this is every Redskins fan experience we
start talking about the team in yo you
go RG three looks like a catfish that's
memes pop up of him looking like a
catfish yep right come on bro especially
that one I could give you that ever be
back in Idol you think so Sam
no no no he's no he he was in somebody's
camp I think last year but you know
what's gonna happen it's gonna happen
with not Tebow Batman's actually played
for the brothers a day drinking a bunch
strong Johnny Manziel it'll happen to
Manziel as well all these guys are gonna
be marquee players in that new XFL from
Jim McMahon jim mcmahon vince mcmahon
vince me i mean it's all about played
football for me it's all about making
money now because because rg3 look if
you're still physically able it's a big
question with him but like and you're
still confident in your ability to be
quarterback you also have to pay me a
lot because I'm not putting my knee out
there for you know ten thousand dollars
but if you're gonna take me in a big
offer from Vince McMahon which I think
that leaves gonna fail horrible sure but
help some of those guys like them like
Johnny Manziel will sell tickets in
whatever shady town is and it to get two
million bucks to play quarterback
yeah but selling tickets versus the
production cost of putting on a league
like the XFL that thing is gonna fold or
you they can get a couple people have
name value RG three Manziel yeah people
are gonna tune in man and there's some
guys who flamed out and sometimes people
flame out i'd like duke my opinion is
vince young if he was white he would
have stayed in the NFL much longer it's
a he dude yeah i said oh when yeah he
had a mental problems but so do a lot of
I mean like dude nope like half the
Seahawks hate Russell Wilson like he's
the guy they don't like [ __ ] out
what's his name Tannehill for the
Dolphins [ __ ] giant [ __ ] man you hear
the stories about all the [ __ ] they did
like the coach telling the DB's like
Dhoni receptors ball don't make him feel
bad
you know I'm saying it's like like
there's a lot of peope wrestle Wilson is
everything because Russell Wilson his
teammates can hate him but they know he
puts the time in you could not say that
about Vince Young was in a car were like
crying with a gun in his mouth yeah but
just like watching watching the house
working on the offseason changing his
diet Vincent never did any of that [ __ ]
rg3 literally does everything he can
every waking and sleeping hour to become
a better quarterback and you cannot say
that about Vince Young okay all right
someone got touched by Vince Young at
some point oh I like Vince Young and I
got if I'm a GM I don't not in my
quarterback
I'm not giving what but if I XFL and I
go hey dude you want to give it a shot
sure he's got name recognition one game
he's gonna set he's gonna sell it's
gonna be curiosity and then we're not
gonna do that name recognition
I still man general I think he does beep
off a little bit yeah but it's not gonna
I'm telling you it's not gonna last I
think it I think it last this season
here's what they have to do they have to
take two I think they should get I think
it should be Ironman football where you
play both sides of the ball I also think
you know what else we exciting we said
it's on the ship before full integration
land mines actual land mines land mines
you running with the ball oh here comes
a touch on put home you blow yourself up
yeah watch that yeah I'd be a fan roses
down yeah the last time I watched sports
was probably when the Bulls had Michael
Jordan and Scottie Pippen that's your
last time what about Super Bowl parties
and [ __ ] I mean oh I'm like a
fair-weather fan I mean you're super
tall boyfriend don't like to watch
sports together he used to play sports
that's why he hates he's so tall what is
he six six six nine in heels yeah is he
one of those guys who like they like
used to play basketball but he's sick of
getting asked if he plays because he's
tall Oh
soccer player and women's volleyball
player he was a quarterback for Boulder
Colorado of 200 I think then he stopped
playing or something happen he
discovered weed yeah yeah that and the
my friends in high school discovered
weed and Slayer and they stopped playing
football right they're like [ __ ] it
let's just smoke weed worship the devil
see I started early in junior high I had
no choice had tits so I was like well I
guess I'll yeah started Sam
so [ __ ] true I love roads the stories
have been like 14 dude and rails of
cocaine dude and rails those Albanians
they search out early no my parents were
strict was the opposite I had to lie
they may become such a criminal I'm such
a good liar that sentence started weird
and I ended so let me ask you one sip of
tequila I can't even tell you what
aquiline your parents make you come so
you were doing coke early right that was
my favorite no hours ago oh no I I think
I try got offered drugs a lot when I was
younger because people thought I was
just older and annoy Illinois oh yeah
yeah so I mean I tried it but it wasn't
like I was doing it like every day I was
I smoke more weed than anything and you
know my parents were strict so anytime I
got outside of the house I was a [ __ ]
animal Mike I'll try every every drug
whatever yeah so refresh it like
everytime you could so you think if it
was more like I would be such a nice
person if my parents were just most my
friends that had parents that like just
let him do whatever the [ __ ] they want
you know mom was like don't hang out
with her should her mom's an alcoholic
she'd the bar all night [ __ ] that she's
[ __ ] that it you can't hang out with
them those kids turned out great
straight-a students going to college
like you know I did too but kind of roll
in the dirt like this is why I never
want to be a parent because there's no
good there's no tried in a true way too
because sometimes kids are held back
from all that stuff and they end up
great sometimes not sometimes parents
let them do whatever the [ __ ] they want
to end up great sometimes they end up
not like who wants to do that wants to
be it would be in charge of another
human beings I've never understood it
now that I'm older I really do
appreciate what my mom did and what when
my dad did because it makes me realize
I'm like they're just trying to [ __ ]
jack me you probably had play cups by
[ __ ] well worried about me they're
like dude she's she's gonna be exposed
to all this [ __ ] you know and they're
foreigners they have no idea mentality
oh my god they're just yeah so I I get
it's probably different when you have a
little girl versus a little boy too of
course all my brothers were running
rampant yeah they do whatever the [ __ ]
they wanted but me it was like no well
because I feel like boys are ke
when they're super young and you're like
no stop don't do that and then you get
the teenagers then you're like okay for
the most part they're gonna survive then
you got a daughter you're like I gotta
keep dicks out of this chick for as long
as I [ __ ] can yes cuz I'm not ready
to be a grandparent yeah and that's a
real thing you're like if the girl goes
out gets crazy she could come on me like
I'm pregnant you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] 45
and I'm a grandpa I wasn't allowed to
date either oh that's gonna be that's
the thing it's like like condoms work
very well and keeping your daughter
inside you locked in your house works
even better if you're trying to prevent
pregnancy like if I decay to be like the
purge everyday just like all the walls
come down you're sleeping in the panic
room nobody's getting in there that's
not real and then they go to college and
they just go batshit crazy
yeah you know I got a daughter I would
shove it back in my wife and I'd be like
fix yourself like a whistle and like a
sweatshirt that says coach like you just
want a boys run laughs so you get a
penis just tell the doctor to put a dick
on him and call of a [ __ ] it 20:18
[ __ ] I have that fix it have
that graduation sir yourself you have a
child that is Vegas we don't know it's a
blurry gray area that's the futures if
it comes out a girl they just have a
prosthetic dick waiting just like okay
we're you just gonna sell this on nah
you just have a rack of dicks and a
staple gun so we just our game here was
a chaos like I remember when the
all-star game came here in 2004 yeah
now's when Shaq and Kobe we're still
going [ __ ] nuts right I believe 2004
Shaq we still here I mean you know those
early Staples Center yeah I think it was
a year after he left because because the
Lakers made it to those finals against
the Pistons but they lost I got here I
got here the same year I did they are so
it was like crazy on the strip oh yeah
it became a police day and I was on ha
Bulova I'm like I've never seen so many
cops in my [ __ ] I mean like do cops
pulling over cos that's how many cops
and I was at the store at Saturday night
and a lot of the parties that they were
at like that the players were hosting
stuff happened up on sunset so you had
the slam dunk contest and the
three-point contest this Saturday did
this past Saturday yeah and which I
thought about going to I was doing an
event downtown during the day and I was
like you know Staples Center is five
blocks I could walk you know how much
premium tickets like just like for not
not front-row but like four level
tickets to the slam dunk contest one
hundred thirty two hundred is what I saw
in stuff a premium yeah I mean up in the
upper ones were like twelve hundred
would you see hot chicks on their phone
the whole time like oh my god this is an
NBA guy to [ __ ] get inside though
there's an app for it there is there's
an app for where athletes are hanging at
that chicks are just like Oh [ __ ]
so-and-so's at this club groupies will
wrap up out of the floor it's amazing
it's for athletes and actors it's
amazing for these that's good that would
make sense if I could get knocked up by
a billion a millionaire but that's the
[ __ ] the problem is these poor ladies
are getting knocked up by like bench
guys and they're like going to euro and
the Europe and they're like I'm going to
Serbia I hope I get [ __ ] pay you know
you find out you're six months pregnant
they have that the conversation hoodie
it's not over like no no you're not no
nobody's nobody signing you like depose
in love with a wreath or flank and nail
her just to get his hand in her pocket
guy it's the opposite you see a super
famous chick and you knock her up you
could be [ __ ] dude for [ __ ] child
support I had a buddy of mine who
knocked up this chick who is this
daughter of a billionaire and the amount
of child support she wanted was [ __ ]
insane so it's like were you like [ __ ]
you want [ __ ] 10 grand a month
that's the sandy bacon court your honor
artificial defenses guys if you wanted
to go to the dunk contest where would
you go Sam
but you gonna try to say you guys up in
case you get on the dock on time you
could have banned the dunk contest and
you go to bat des I bet the acai for all
your bet needs go to bet deicide comm
use a promo code punch 25 and get $25
betting cash we had some UFC's we I mean
dude the sports are going nah baseball's
come March Madness is coming on that's a
great thing about house Albania doing in
the Olympics can we make some bets on
them any I have no idea you don't even
see how your peoples are doing I don't
even think they're in the Olympics do
you guys even have a flag let's be
honest we do but you know it's communist
for a long time but they're built like
me so why not are they even are they are
here are they there
yes you have a hug to ll5 oh you just
went for alpine competitors Alpine
that's it okay Wow look up Kosovo oh
yeah is that what you are yeah no
they're all being as well so after the
war they liberated yes no one person in
the Olympics that is in two events one
competitor it's one event together
Albania they're good is there good snow
in Albania is that why they scold yes
there's a lot of mountains everywhere
it's beautiful is that where you live in
a cold place yet you don't do any of the
sports it's not a busy Mediterranean and
really human trafficking and rutting
it's like California weather
oh really beautiful the mountains like
an island basically mountains are
different so the girl that live up in
the mountains look differently but
Mediterranean people there sure dark and
there by the ocean you know it's
different
they look like Greeks and freakin
Italians you know for sure I found out
I'm Russian Armenian last night did you
do the day I wouldn't go so happy no
wonder you're obsessed of the Internet
what no this urgent chick was like where
you from I go I don't know the exact
place my I'm body
they called me body it would
is a certain village in Armenia she's
like oh you're [ __ ] Russian Armenian
I'm like I didn't want to be that
[ __ ] filthy Persian army all mixed
with [ __ ] we really are we really are so
I do the Armenian benefit all the time
they show up and like Albanians here and
they're like we're not [ __ ] or
meaning she's like I'm [ __ ] Albanian
[ __ ]
I don't want pure [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm feel
like I'm in a but Albanian wedding I'm
yeah and this way I tell the girls on my
glisten they're gonna be a pain in the
[ __ ] ass they're not gonna sit what
they want to sit but they will fight
over the tab you will not worry about
them walking out and they're gonna take
care of you just [ __ ] deal with it
yes deal with it we do they're nice
people they're just pain in ass it's
like yeah yeah they get road rage and
their hearts explode because they have
heart attacks by 45 everyone's mixed at
everything eventually it's just come I'm
65 percent french-canadian 70 percent
Swedish and 20 percent bad at math yeah
you just might be the contender for the
next Argos so your car must be done huh
oh so Sam is going to get the update on
his detailed car so tea but what
happened with the car detailing okay so
we well rose and I were here first move
Johnny we're staying outside having a
cigarette and we see Sam pull up and
Johnny kindly walks up to this car
behind his car and moves the empty to a
street trash can kind of forward so Sam
at a place to park very nice this guy
goes nuts
this guy's yelling at Johnny Sam gets
out of the car now Sam's Jana at this
guy and this guy's like you can do that
I've been here for 20 years Sam because
I've been here for 30 years so why can't
I move a [ __ ] trash can they're going
back and forth forever forever then we
get in here and this other guy comes up
he's like hey listen I detail cars does
anybody need their car detai and then
sam being me now that we know russian
army is tackling this guy about how he
needs a seats cleaned in this [ __ ]
car and [ __ ] they go outside look at the
car the guys like leaving your car keys
and it's aunt Sam who doesn't trust
anybody's like you leaving your [ __ ]
car keys bro Mike just gonna let you
steal my car and if I swap car keys yeah
uh-huh
he's like a rocker I don't steal [ __ ] or
what yeah yeah don't steal [ __ ] it's
like that's exactly what somebody that
would steal something would say to me
yeah so then we start the podcast
example [ __ ] all my personal
informations you know oh my all my
personal informations in my car so then
he goes and just grabs all of this which
is just like everything that has his
address I guarantee it's not everything
if you've owned a car for like a week
you're like oh this is where I'll keep
all my stuff this is real keep two weeks
go by it's all over and everywhere in
the car yeah cars halfway to Barstow
like why would you hire somebody that
you obviously have massive trust issues
with right out the gate I would just
rather drive a shitty looking car than
deal with people in general like because
you it happens a lot in LA but somebody
will pull up next to the BA you need
that dent buffed out oh no no yeah I
mean not from you like when I had a
Camry I'd always get a note it was
always my Camry was always like filthy
outside cuz I'm like [ __ ] it had a dent
in the back there like we buy junk cars
man what the [ __ ] like every day it was
like just like a little card from
different places that's our thing that's
hurtful
yeah and hurt my feelings a little bit
you know it's just almost like they want
a friend yeah yeah like they're just
pulling up they're like hey I could buff
your car up but I just really need
someone to talk to for a couple hours
and and I'm not about a movie question
for you have you seen this movie on
Netflix called radius really it's called
radius
I've not seen radius I'm talking about I
am Not sure no it's crazy it's like this
guy like and his girl wake up from this
accident and it's like a lightning
strike and they both laugh I'm like
amnesia or something and it's slowly
trying to piece their life together and
then at the the crazy thing is at the
very end turns out that guy was a serial
killer the whole time and was trying to
kill her spoiler alert I don't know if
you say that first or last but let's cut
happened in that entire movie I was like
what an interesting twist this is weird
this is a weird time when the spoiler
you just gave unsolicited by the way
yeah
actually made me want to see the show or
the movie more you're welcome kind of
like like it's like memento I was like
where is this movie going oh he's the
killer the whole time alert yeah stop
you don't even know I move you
how was your detail yeah it's like go
nice that's good you know that guys
beating off in your car how many pounds
have come did he take out a yes okay you
just got rid of calm and blood with come
that's how you get come come stayed out
more come that works with wine - you get
wine out of your hair gum what are you
getting that's how we do the dishes at
the Comedy Store
Oh red wine stain put some white wine in
there and take it right out
come on peanut butter get why now a
radius that's what it's called yeah that
guy is that serial killers the whole
time I think that's how you said it good
this you totally think they're gonna
fall in love but that he was trying to
kill her - it's weird
all right you want to see how good you
guys are a movie trivia
sure of course okay but what we do is
like I like to know your strengths so
you have to give me what category movie
you think would be bad silent film now
all three of us are a team and we're
trying to come up with answers are we
competing against I think you're
competing against each other okay I know
where Sam's going training porn I I hope
you picked some of the films I was in
I'm pretty good keep feeling an actor an
actress the director is genre
um let's do topic eighties comedies
eighties comedies why not okay you're
gonna go with eighties comedies sure I
don't know why not all right what's your
affair to me
what's your category what sure you know
I will go with the eighties comedies
maybe why no you pick what everyone team
yeah we're t are we all play against
each other
yeah oh okay whatever they want I would
just say for me slapstick comedy because
I've seen slapstick comedy yes maybe
early 90s okay could do 80s okay okay
throw it out there all right I mean
they're day drinking so they're cool
whatever
yeah we're going dancing after this yeah
we're gonna go slapstick comedy first
okay these questions to Rose
however if Rose misses it either one of
you guys can buy okay how do we buzz by
punching you punch him in the neck for
not the neck punch but whatever makes
you guys like a [ __ ] job just good
job I really hope Rose gets this
question sweet sauce you get you get 15
seconds then waiter waiter waiter we get
a little more sweet sauce for the kids
over come on wait there's a flow all
right rose yeah you have to name the
movie the 1991 film that stars Charlie
Sheen as a hotshot pilot named topper
Harley oh these hotshots right yeah
point what you're off the album Thriller
cycle George what's in your coffee cup
no you guys carry questions like this
what song did Michael Jackson Thriller
people with
[Laughter]
all right DL is mine your question the
Naked Gun yeah came out in 1987 it had a
sequel The Naked Gun two and a half
mm-hmm what was the subtitle of the
Naked Gun two and a half naked gun two
and a half electric boogaloo incorrect
and either one y'all steal it saying
again when it can Nate what is the
subtitle of the Naked Gun two and a half
two point was something no it was two
and a half and a half yeah I don't
citizens on patrol no but that's a great
Johnny for the steal Oh
Errol Aaron's got it Erin you got a chop
in the neck smell of fear maybe I'll
bring Erin as my teammate was on that
one right yeah that's funny
he's great that's like the Hori I just
watch that document document I guess it
was on Netflix Padre Simpson oh there
was a documentary on the show at the
same time show so [ __ ] guilty okay
let me ask you something when that whole
thing came out was that 90 yeah 3 94 94
is how old were you at 94 I was in fifth
grade
oh did it resonate with you at all what
was going on he was guilty every was on
TV I would I would I would go to the
principal's office off things again
trouble all the time cuz you're dating
him yeah I was blowing Oh Mike come on
give me straight seas hello hello who's
this Jewish Shaffir is it Jew Shaffir
Harry yeah had it and we love what is he
in the outback [ __ ] him that was a brief
appearance [ __ ] you go on tell us about
you new guy friends I'm lucky I guess
tell you what you should have it all
right we can't hear you we can't now oh
all right
hello Ari [ __ ] fathers go to God
we're on the phone we can hear you you
[ __ ] things are you ordering food what
do you think this is post it post rates
are you there okay
let's talk about dating the principle
again Gohan no basically the OJ Simpson
trial was everywhere so that was like
the whole thing my mom everybody would
you remember this 294 and I want to know
J to be innocent so bad I did like the
black people because the Naked Gun
movies me I'm a huge NFL fan I did not
want that man to be guilt yeah
and also I think the Rodney King thing
really helped him out because they're
like we can't have another [ __ ] riot
I know we are you guys black we were
like dude no this was planted there was
that guy was a genius master Pierre oh
boy you're not Shapiro Cochran Cochran
was just like knew how to manipulate the
whole team was great yeah and just the
fat cop in prosecution just made
Kardashian both dead karma karma
[ __ ] incorrect images coming
into a piggy bank that whole time yeah
well they're all witches dude they're
into some dark [ __ ] do whatever it is
everybody they date life disintegrates
seemed a little forced in the show the
people versus OJ when the Kardashian
daughters just happened to like hop in
like just don't do it in Kimmy's room
I'm like oh you just wanted to say Kim
Kardashian are you sorry are you there
hello all right can you hear me dumb
[ __ ] yeah Ari welcome are you in
Australia no microphone detected oh I
hear we hear you re so it's not us it's
you know I think its own hello okay good
let's do this now in the middle of the
show there we go
yep yep yep check all those yes hello
Ari
are you alive god damn a part of
Australian he's in the gay part where
they have K but thanks so much [ __ ]
so much do you ever see how he's [ __ ]
it has adjustable Crips on it
no just it looks like you go click click
click click click I mean for that as
gross as that is I will say it's
convenient really you know his [ __ ]
looks like a catcher's mitt she's right
here
she's so quiet you know talking about
are his ass home he reminds being my dog
my dog's butthole
it literally looks like a heart when I
was in a strip club I was at a strip
club right the first like month I lived
out here my buddies from college came
out I went to the strip club and one of
my buddies like from Chicago knees like
man I'm not paying a [ __ ] dollar I
don't wanna go to [ __ ] strip clubs or
waste your [ __ ] money I'm not gonna
spend a [ __ ] dollar today my friend
you have yeah yeah of course and we're
sitting like right here and we're like
the only people there because it's like
early in the evening were just like
let's go oh you're hitting the buffet
the lunch buffet is like seven ish now
is seven or something and then said his
girls on his pole and it's like one of
those all nude ones and so right in
front of like my buddy's face who's
bitching about money she's like opens
our ass and like flexes a butthole like
that and he goes that's got to be worth
a buck right so her bajo we get even
women I'll spend hundreds of dollars and
make sure Jesus cause I feel I I don't
really feel bad but I see the work
they're putting in on my food with her
[ __ ]
she put her disgusting puss on the
ground this is that body shop oh yeah
cuz they're all naked which I didn't
know I was like what I was trying to get
[ __ ] up and I was like no alcohol
after after my pod can't after my TV
show I get my check I would go to the
shop and get hand jobs in celebration
here you go
open it you can't say that they're gonna
shut the place down now oh I mean this
was like [ __ ] 10 years ago now to cry
statue limitations sorry are you there
yeah well it's not you it's not us it's
you we hear you okay no thank you we
could hear you but you couldn't hear our
Mary
we've been talked to by ATC they don't
want us wearing any more okay could you
please
watch her language where we're trying to
re Olympics fever out there yeah are you
really gonna Bob are you really going
I'm looking at the planet to [ __ ] lose
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] see your
brother on TV lie to join up right there
in the on live television yet dog that's
pretty [ __ ] irresponsible as a man why
why is there responsible could be in the
weed with me [ __ ] you know I'm
saying thank you dog no no are you guys
do a lot of like a cross training and
all this are you getting in are you
telling me the Diaz brothers are getting
into Winter Olympic training getting in
dog we've always been into [ __ ] Winter
Olympics dog I always been doing i
cross-country ski in the [ __ ] summer
dog is that in Stockton or where do you
do that in to elevated mountains or
where do you do that dog I only trained
in [ __ ] Stockton man okay doctor
number one Olympic Winter Olympics
[ __ ] training ground there is dog I
don't know if that's all welcome welcome
to Stockton trance is [ __ ] Olympic dog
yeah there's not a lot of snow in
Stockton I think you need snow for the
Winter Olympics is there no snow I mean
it's kind of noise don't know for
[ __ ] Winter Olympics [ __ ] job yeah
no [ __ ] [ __ ] Stockton
I just think the training would be hard
without snow I mind it could be wrong
where there's a will there's a way bro I
train on the [ __ ] luge in the [ __ ]
popsicle parking lot dog I think that
would be going very slowly slow moving
lose you know what do you do in Utah dog
what do I do it [ __ ] Utah dog yeah
hanging out you know [ __ ] hanging out
getting some Sun and just hanging out
why Utah you know what I say doc why not
Utah you know I'm saying I get that ah
are you gonna do CRE shows yeah I am dog
I'm also taking a look there's a [ __ ]
big pontoon manufacturer up here and I'm
just taking a tour the [ __ ] facility
I know you guys do like to pawn to boats
now how did you last you time you called
you and your brother were starting a
your own fighting League where you guys
jump out of airplanes and fight to the
ground and loser doesn't get his
parachute opened how's the dog I'm
[ __ ] for no and that [ __ ] dog
obviously you're on the phone right nice
to meet ya so you're just fighting
people targeted in the ground yeah if
you talk I'll pull my parachute about
maybe like 17 feet above the ground last
minute dog up you know if you want to
pass yeah like at 17 feet I'll pull my
chute then I ain't never had a [ __ ]
problem I would respect that I respect
that like actually they're a lot like l
ron hubbard just these amazing feats of
like crazy
robert you get you dog o
Dianetics had to hold you get you
[ __ ] books here oh that's cool that's
cool that's amazing so when you get a
black belt you're clear is that what
you're saying yeah dog I'm [ __ ] like
I'm real high up there dog I get to talk
to aliens and [ __ ] almost that's yes P
that's what he was taken that's the
truth that's the jiu-jitsu he was
studying that's why you can talk to that
man yeah I understand now have you
gotten into any trouble with GSP are you
guys on good terms last I mean you
buried him in a refrigerator box you
catfished him with
to Rousey you've done a lot of things on
our show you had a dating game and then
catfished him again a lot of bad things
have happened to George st. Pierre on
the show because of you you lock him in
a basement tried to get him sober off of
it was snorting kitty litter yeah my
[ __ ] weight class no more so like you
and I are fine
oh you guys are cool now yeah she comes
back to 70 we got a big [ __ ] problem
you on same dog are you still dating
around to Rousey I mean you know dog
what are you what your definition is
dating yes you married but like this you
come over sometimes are we 69 maybe it's
at least acquaintances yeah sure for
sure yeah I don't know that dating dog I
mean I respected she's a [ __ ] married
woman but you know a 69 and 80 [ __ ]
cheating yeah is that official rule 69
somebody you're not cheating that's more
intimate good sixty-nining a lot now I
mean like is it a spillin I think these
kids are so aggressive I hate it you
have your nose looks bothered like
that's why you got bleach or [ __ ] man
seriously bleach in your hair so I'm
more of a 73 what do you mean that's
where it it's like you're passed out and
then I just put a pillow on my lap and
then flip you over and just 69 Jesus
don't do anything just lay there so
flexible can you bend your neck around
so I'll heat you ass and then chill bend
your neck all the way around and stuff
might be you know what I'm saying
suck your what so she like puts her ass
cheeps in my face and that bends her
neck all the way around like looking
like giraffe I don't I'm not a [ __ ]
mathematician but I think it's a hundred
and eighty degrees such a d
yeah such my dick yeah oh thank you no
no I think that that's what they call it
yeah oh now I like to party you know dog
that's why I'm in [ __ ] Utah Utah's
the [ __ ] party capital of the world
that's insane is that right you told us
a party capital of the world
are you now I got voted [ __ ] best
party state in the [ __ ] world like
six years in a row by what Mormon
magazine you talk about those [ __ ]
Morgan's they love it man they [ __ ]
love the party no that's what uh the the
kiss said they said where are the best
groupies they said Utah because again
going back to when you can't do anything
you wanted oh I think I might [ __ ]
join dude I might join that organization
Nix they're gonna be they're gonna be
any talk of you uh you [ __ ] re in the
ass while you're there are you gonna do
any really raising this guy in podcast
dawg I ain't into that I ain't into the
gay stuff but like you see and I like
you know if we want to put our dicks
together and go in like I eat the whole
[ __ ] thing up with [ __ ] cup of
noodles dawg let me ask you something so
it's not gay if you and Ari are both in
the same hole in a chick using her as a
windsock to [ __ ] basically stop
homosexuality is that what you're
telling me is that like some weird fine
print to that dick the dick but since
there's a girl a Christian podcast like
that's like a gentlemen's agreement when
you go in you're like it's called the
gentlemen's agreement I like that I like
that line yeah
it's like we're touching but like we're
touching for Maddox that's called
teamwork yeah they do it in golf after
the round with your best friend like
some other dudes for like a girl because
she said that then she'll buckle you
know I'm saying no actually you know
like me and kill like we'll make out for
like 20 minutes and then like some girl
be like you know I'll [ __ ] bolt you
after that yeah that's never happened to
me so the other 50 it's just you and
Gillman can out forever without any risk
there's no [ __ ] reward you know
saying dog man I've made I will kill his
old man two [ __ ] [ __ ] who chicks you
know I'm saying sounds like you know
Melendez family I've done a lot of man
without their [ __ ] white people don't
but [ __ ] Mexican dudes they [ __ ]
get it
I respect Mexicans dude I'm hot dog and
I'm a [ __ ] get high as [ __ ] and I'm
only talking to our okay talk about a
little day drink you know it's your
classic hang up right there it's a good
visit by Ari that's a quality quality
phone call yeah I mean can you imagine
how random it is that he is there and
there's [ __ ] there's certain people I
might enter that lottery for though like
if you to make out with a dude and then
one of you gets to go on like it's
almost like one of you wins to go
progress to like so uh female you're
really attracted to oh let me find I
would love to know who made your list
what dudes are you willing to make out
to do a threesome with another hot chick
who it's a bet I have to start with who
the woman is well who do I pick so like
if it's somebody it's like super hot
right let's go no let's go super ugly of
course who problem what's the lowest I
go yeah
super-hottie are we talking celebrities
or within the realm of reason of like I
thinking I think I'm within the realm of
reason for celebrities okay YouTube is
huge these days okay all right let's go
what he's got to have a good mouth like
what's going on so let's go right are we
saying what celebrity would you get
there's the prize and then the celebrity
you have to make out with know your
friends yeah I'll have to make out while
you're and how long is the make out
though that's Oh two hours two hours
catch tongs I just go like this no
you've got a French kiss - it's like are
so like if I'm going for Julia right
minute yeah I think you just wanna make
out with your male friends and you're
just Betty White okay I'd totally [ __ ]
for the story all right so let's say for
example the seal Baba Roberts still very
attractive and it's a great story if
she's winning an Oscar and you can tell
all your friends hey remember that time
I made out with one of you but then I go
who are you trying to impress your mom's
that's a very attractive woman
yeah it's a pretty woman still like
let's say like Kate Upton who would I
make out but the price here's a problem
I gotta make out with let's say for
example French I got a make out with
Triple E for 15 minutes to then only be
able to last two minutes with Kate Upton
yeah it's not like you know kissy would
you do that I think you'd make out with
Triple E for 15 I think I want Triple E
for a turkey sandwich yeah that's true
all right so we're cat lady [ __ ] when
you think the hottest Kate option
picture versus like Julie on the red
carpet like I'm sure Julia's got scandal
we're talking today though are you are
we going back in time and pretty woman
Julie Rob we can go with modern-day Kate
Upton if you want if that makes you guys
feel comfortable I try to pick a woman
your own age and you guys rebelled
against why for somebody
all day why I was trying to class up I
was trying to class it up Julia Roberts
has a better body than Kate Upton whoo
and here comes the cattiness you're
looking nice I think it's a great body
said it was a bad body yeah I think
that's I think it's amazing only drunk
chicks day drinkin would ever think okay
trust me I have a high telephoto
Photoshop oh that is great natural wreck
but Julie Roberts in her heyday hey
bring out the hammer
amber better bring out Amber Rose bring
out this bring out the hammer it the
only person on the show that's attracted
Amber Rose but tripley's cuckoo fur just
bring out the [ __ ] okay so who do you
make out with for Amber Rose then so
you're an ass white black you gotta make
like her [ __ ] yeah you gotta go you
gotta make out with Mike black for a
better body than both those [ __ ] okay
I'm more I would make out with Mike
black for three minutes to lick her
[ __ ] my quack really the liquor
[ __ ] yeah I would I would fight why
Mike black though because he just threw
moms randomly said that okay yeah what
if I drop see he's aa on my hit list of
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah you have to pick a guy
whatever you had to make our you would
rather make out with first of all that
this is his story not this guy
uh if I give you Amber Rose if I give
you ten minutes with Amber Rose okay
will you give me ten minutes of make out
with boom Shakalaka I have to yeah I
stay I will identify but I can guarantee
the win because in the original scenario
it might be you might not get to make
out that's not and not pull out like she
has to take the pill two of them she has
to take to Plan B's ten minutes and I
can just blast away as she yells
Rachel's hair whatever she wants to do
but all that the BB gun ticket but it's
her decision to take Plan B you can't
tell her what to do no no no she has to
take you can't no you can't tell me what
you have to it's her body yes my where
scenario where I might be making out
with Mike black to [ __ ] impregnate no
I said shock like that's too much you're
racist
click clack clack oh for sure for sure
like that top picture you might get me
the name of those pictures over there
name is a step aside chibi Tripoli loves
Mike black I'm not afraid of that would
you make out with Boone to not have to
make out with Mike black he has good
dental hygiene I bring boon to get a lot
of work a lot of cleaning teeth cleaning
teeth he's very uh good teeth here's a
germaphobe he's a germaphobe I feel like
he would not be that bad besides I don't
know how old he is Robert now and you're
Julia Roberts he's about Julia Roberts
his age no frickin nature she's really
pretty
are there any TMZ photos of Boone
getting out of the ocean like just like
one time you read something about
swimming some I go can you swim I never
thought about asking you that can you
swim I try I got that's not an answer
that like what I like it like do you
ever go to the pool do you know I think
me I don't know I go boom Shakalaka if I
dropped you in a pool what would happen
he goes out drown okay then you cannot
swim Wow three different ways was a
maybe it was all this amazing talk and
more on this exciting episode of painful
hung sports real quick tell them where
they can find all your podcast and
everything because you are consumed with
snapchat and [ __ ] God how dare you
hey I see another way let me come on
your house and dog likes more crazy
was it makes me laugh I like to watch
myself like it's maybe you know I don't
like creepy they are look it makes me
die laughing though I have fun doing it
anyway you could find me with sweet
three trolls my episodes have you done
uh we're going on eight tomorrow's our
next release you put out one a week one
a week yeah yeah record every Sunday at
the world famous cam a nice no no
and what do you rack people like what is
the show well basically it's we have
like troll the week we it's very topical
so we take a lot of stories that are
hilarious you know we talked about
[ __ ] we talked about people who act
children who actually believe themselves
and kill themselves like there's all
these really weird statistics and you
know we we go off kilter and say all
kinds of weird stuff but that's
basically just a bit and how can they
find such me because you have the
weirdest social media here's the thing
we're on iTunes Google Play you do look
good look up pod bean we're on all kinds
of stuff yeah you have you'll find it
it's we three trolls so it sweet w3
you're the free of this Black Eyed Peas
trolls say one more time w3 thr33 trolls
okay and Zaphod on juanita at it's good
luck finding that safa Don Juanita I
love how you said slower like it would
make more sense good luck where you
gonna be
I mean where can they find you at Mark
Ellis live on Twitter Instagram all that
good stuff that's we can get tickets for
the the movie trivia Schmo down live at
the Portal Theatre in Hollywood North
Hollywood on March 15th live movie
trivia and this boon video is just
mesmerizing thanks for having me man
twisted genius I need less thoughts
tchibo no okay thank you guys this has
been a day drinking podcast of punch
drunk sports where winners win I love
you think for having me on